[Music]
red table talk made its official return
with season five on Wednesday and while
the first episode is about Janelle
Monae's sexual identity and coming out
publicly Jada Pinkett Smith and the show
took a moment to address Will Smith
slapping Chris Rock on stage at the
Oscars by sharing a message prior to the
start of the episode it reads
considering all that has happened in the
last few weeks the Smith family has been
focusing on deep healing some of the
discoveries around our healing will be
shared at the table when the time calls
until then the table will continue
offering itself to powerful inspiring
and healing testimonies like that of our
incredibly impressive first guess thanks
for joining us Jada if we don't talk
about it we're not going to get to the
other side the premiere episode for
season 5 was filmed before the infamous
Oscars incident that led to Will Smith
being banned from the Academy's events
for 10 years
oh wow the decision to ban will was made
following a meeting held by the academy
Board of Governors in an open letter the
president and CEO of the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences writes
quote the 94th Oscars were meant to be a
celebration of the many individuals in
our community who did incredible work
this past year however those moments
were overshadowed by the unacceptable
and harmful Behavior we saw Mr Smith
exhibit on stage the letter goes on to
apologize for not adequately addressing
the situation in the room adding that
they fell short and were unprepared for
the unprecedented in a statement to ET
the 53-year-old King Richard Starr
responded to the ruling saying quote I
accept and respect the Academy's
decision
how are you doing good you good the day
after the academy made their decision
Jada made her first public appearance
since the Oscars the 50-year-old was all
smiles as she showed her support for
Gray's Anatomy Creator Shonda Rhimes at
the grand opening of the Rimes
Performing Arts Center in Los Angeles
Will's wife really should have been
given some consideration EG recently
spoke with NBA legend Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar and he believes that Jada's
voice wasn't heard after Will's Oscar
slap one more thing you wrote a much
talked about opinion about the slap and
what it meant and can you expand upon
that about what you thought about that
moment and how it affected people
well I you know I just felt that uh
Will's wife really should have been
given some consideration as to you know
how she felt about it
and what she wanted to do about it I
mean they just ignored her
all together and I I didn't uh
I didn't think that made much sense
[Music]